one of the best ways to earn money from
home and build a life in a business on
your own terms is creating an online
course you know the opportunity is
massive right now and in this deep dive
training i'm gonna be breaking down the
best way to market and sell your course
this year but i'm not sure if you've
seen this article yet
about the e-learning market that's gonna
reach a trillion dollars within six
years so when we talk about the
opportunity this isn't hype this is a
very real industry that is exploding and
i'm sure that's why you're watching this
video because you want to tap into this
but maybe you're frustrated because
you're not getting online course sales
right now maybe you're frustrated
because you know social media organic
reach is down you've been trying to
promote or build a following get noticed
and competition continues to rise or
maybe you're frustrated because paid ads
are expensive and with the ios 14 update
that disrupted everybody ad accounts are
getting shut down and of course paid ads
are awesome for promoting your course
but they can be frustrating and even
risky if you lose a bunch of money maybe
you've thought about working with a
marketing agency but who can you trust
who can you hire and is it going to be a
waste of money paying somebody who won't
even generate sales for your online
course well there's a better way and
it's free and we're going to be talking
about it in this video we're going to be
talking about the three-step process for
selling your online course even if you
don't have a following yet and how to
get the perfect customer for your course
coming to you and also how to generate
sales for your course 24 7 even when
you're not
working so if you're fired up smash the
like button this is the coffee with
kennel show my name is sean cannell and
for your convenience time codes and
chapters have been added to this video
you can also check out show notes and
resources to help you get better results
on youtube and generate more core sales
if we're just meeting i've grown a
couple youtube channels to over a
hundred thousand subscribers uh one to
almost two million now i'm most proud of
though um our students um many who have
started from zero and it's really not
too late to start youtube in fact one of
our students just started in the last
six months already has 53 000
subscribers and has only posted 23
videos so far so if you want to actually
learn how to grow your youtube channel
as well as generate sales for your
online course definitely hit the
subscribe button and sean why would you
have the authority to talk about
generating sales for your online course
you know you need to be careful who you
follow and we are approaching right now
at think media my company almost 10
million dollars in online course sales
we're about 9.3 or 9.6 right now and so
pretty soon we'll be crossing eight
figures in online course sales so this
is a proven system that's really going
to work for you so i encourage you
buckle your seatbelt so here's the
strategy um we're gonna use youtube to
attract
our ideal customers on autopilot and
exponentially multiply our online course
sales i've got three tips for you but
this is the system we're going to be
using youtube
and in a particular way so that you're
attracting the ideal customers the
people who'd be interested in your
online course on autopilot and i'll show
you that that's a real thing and we'll
create exponential online course sales
doing it here's an example this is
simply soccer youtube channel they're
actually a part of our program called
video ranking academy and
um they teach obviously soccer tips
right so
how to follow your instincts in soccer
the five mistakes average players make
in matches so they're creating youtube
videos and getting nearly 460 000 views
a month but you might be saying well
that's great for them they already have
an established youtube channel i'm going
to be showing you even if you haven't
posted a video yet how you can tap into
growing your youtube channel especially
if you're making the right videos right
so they're putting out these videos and
then
as you get to know them as you get to
build trust with simply soccer they have
the simply soccer academy which is
actually a monthly membership online
course it's 15 a month so you get
mentored with dave you get exclusive
content you get access to the course so
you can see they're using youtube in a
particular way
and then they're putting out free
valuable content that's leading to
their online course but why youtube
itself and why is it perfect for online
course creators well i don't know if
you've seen but 2.3 billion users are on
youtube now that's monthly active users
so you shouldn't be worried even though
it feels competitive out there and maybe
you're frustrated with sales you
shouldn't be worried if you're saying is
there just anybody you know is there
enough people for me to reach is there
any potential customers
is there anybody that is that would be
interested in buying my online course
the key is you just got to get in front
of them you got to get discovered 2.3
billion people is a massive amount of
people right and here's the cool thing
youtube is a discovery machine and what
i mean by that is when you think about
instagram snapchat linkedin twitter
facebook these are
cool if you get lucky and go viral
organic reach on these platforms is
definitely going down i'm all for social
media but also you have to think about
the user's behavior and intent when
they're on social media so i'm on
instagram i'm not necessarily in a
learning education mindset i'm just
scrolling randomly looking for like a
funny reel looking for you know
some uh snowshoe snowshoes you know
looking for uh you know the accounts i
follow for hobbies or clothing or
snowboarding or whatever what's the
intent of being on some of these social
media platforms did you know that the
intent of 70 of people on youtube is to
solve a problem
so if they're already looking for
education
then they're the perfect person for your
online course versus if they're on
social on facebook just to argue with
their friends and family about politics
come on right you know and so what's the
intent of these different platforms
furthermore these are content feeds
instagram has a feed the facebook feed
the twitter feed the linkedin feed
see these are all content feeds where
youtube is a content
library
that's why you can make a video today
and people will still watch it tomorrow
and they can discover you and your
online
course and so the truth is youtube is
the second largest search engine in the
world
so you have to ask yourself what problem
does your course solve what does your
course
teach
and people are searching for that well
then you need to be putting your content
on youtube so they can discover you how
you help people how your course serves
people because youtube's the second
search engine second largest search
engine in the world google's number one
and a lot of times your youtube videos
can get discovered on google because of
their synergy and their family
and so youtube is a massive opportunity
for course creators in fact
today's sponsor of coffee with kannel is
thinkific and uh you can go to
createwiththink.com
to do a free trial whether you have a
channel about cooking guitar teaching
business coaching or fitness youtube
creators all share something in common a
desire to reach more viewers and make a
bigger impact without trading their time
for money so how do you do that by
creating an online course with thinkific
more than 50 000 course creators have
already used thinkific to build revenue
and educate students worldwide so you
can try thinkific free today at
createwiththink.com but here's what's
crazy when i think about
thinkific as a course creation platform
you know i've talked to team members
there and they say that youtube creators
are their most successful users why
because of the psychology of the
platform if people are already coming to
youtube to learn and be educated and
they can build that trust with you here
on youtube then when you say and hey if
you want to go deeper if you want all of
my content in one place or you just want
my step-by-step course
check it out
and so there's a massive synergy so i
encourage you check out thinkific big
thanks to them for sponsoring today's
deep dive class but here's the three
steps here's step number one you're
going to want to create intent based
youtube videos that attract your ideal
customer
this is huge intent based youtube videos
so what is the intent of the person
coming to youtube here's here's the
truth right if your online course
teaches somebody to play violin and
someone's just randomly on youtube
watching small cats chase around
squirrels and get in fights
in the haystack
like that individual is probably not
going to go from watching the kittens
fight the squirrels in the haystack to
purchasing your violin course this is
not going to happen
but if they're already thinking how does
a beginner get started with violin
they discover your video
well then they're
much more aligned with potentially being
a customer of your online course that is
your violin
master class
so you want to create intent based
videos that are reverse engineered to
actually
attract the ideal customers for your
course so who's the ideal customer for
your course
seventy percent of viewers use youtube
to help solve a problem so you wanna
start making videos that solve problems
so people can discover you here's an
example ketocam this is my friend ben
he's actually one of our students as
well and um he's made a couple videos
and i want you to see these he's got 133
000 subscribers now but these were his
first videos three years ago and they've
certainly got more views because over
time
video uh youtube is the only platform
where your content lives forever
it's like a fine wine your videos get
better with age
like you put them out and they just keep
getting viewed now he put out some
videos
three reasons why people fail on the
keto diet
is the ketogenic diet the best for
weight loss
how to do the ketogenic without a
ketogenic diet without a gallbladder
that's pretty cool that's a very
specific question he's answering so you
don't have a gallbladder you're trying
to
figure out how to do the keto diet you
meet ben
on youtube intent based videos well if
you hang out with ben and you start to
discover he's a super cool guy
desperately wants you to you know
experience your best energy your best
fitness your best health and created
an academy ketocamp academy
that people could be a part of so he's
creating free youtube content and then
he educates people and we'll talk about
exactly how to do that so definitely
stick until the end of the video
um he creates these
free youtube videos and then lets people
know about his deeper dive academy and
can sell his online course see how
powerful this is and so youtube is
amazing and here's what i want you to
see
sometimes things will start out a little
slow on youtube but this is a screenshot
of think media and how many views we get
every 60 minutes
right now we're getting over 7 000 views
every hour
on my main channel think media i don't
know if you can drop a bomb explode head
explode emoji in the comments but that's
crazy seven thousand people are viewing
my videos and now our team's videos
every single hour this is why youtube is
the best because if they're the right
videos and the right people are watching
them well then they might be interested
in going to another level with you in
your online
course seven thousand views every hour
and you go well sean easy for you to say
well not easy for me to say you know i
created my first video 10 years ago on
my main channel like i don't know if
you've ever uh been around but have you
seen this thing
all right so uh this is i guess the
first sean thanks vlog and i'm going to
try to vlog
every single day
so i mean 10 years ago i upload that
thing that video did not do very good
but i stuck with it and now
every two days we get almost 500 000
views on the channel imagine just
getting 10 of those results
50 000 views every two days imagine it's
getting 10 of those results 5
000 views every two days uh 10 of that
imagine just 50 people discovering your
content every two days videos that you
created yesterday that they're still
watching just like ben from keto camp
where he's answering specific questions
and then people can go deeper with him
and again i'll show you how so here's
why youtube is the best it's really the
ideal platform for course creators it's
also strong because the way that
business works is we do business with
people we know
that we like and that we trust
your question is i don't have a
following yet or my following is not
very big well that's the power of
youtube it's a discovery machine so
people actually have to know you
before they can flow you like i heard
someone say that once you know like they
have to know you first you actually have
to get discovered to even have a chance
and not everyone's going to be your
customer not everyone's going to connect
with you your vibe's going to attract
your tribe you're not for everyone don't
worry about not everybody wanting to
subscribe or fall it's not a big deal
like just the power of having a chance
to serve someone add value make a
connection they got to know you because
then they can determine if they like you
and chances are they're not gonna buy
your online course if they don't like
you but that's the power of youtube it's
like a chance to like go on a date
before you get married like you know i
mean i i actually live in las vegas and
so sometimes people are like hey nice to
meet you let's have elvis marius that's
a little rare typically you date first
maybe for a little while so youtube is
this chance to get people to know you
start building a connection with you
start to like you and then start to
trust you because the cool thing is when
you hang out with someone on youtube and
you go shoot this person like really
knows what they're talking about wow i
kind of see this person's values well i
kind of see this person that uh they
know what they're talking about and and
they really care about my success and
they've also helped me get some results
in advance and they've also helped me
you know bring some clarity to some
things oh they've got a way where i
could get everything they have all in
one place in their online course and
it's like an accelerator i'm in
that's how powerful youtube is right and
then once you're getting views 24 7 your
course can ultimately be getting
discovered as you're getting discovered
24 7 whether you're working or not and
to top it all off
youtube is free
i mean for real like you know youtube is
free so like what are you doing you got
to just punch fear in the face punch
perfectionism in the face and press
record start making videos because
really it's on the other side of your
hustle and the right strategies that you
can start getting results for awareness
and selling your online course
and so
the power question is what is one
youtube video idea that would attract
your ideal customer
what is one just one youtube video idea
and um i actually have a class that is
available on demand that will help you
with youtube ideas there's a link to
that in the description but let's think
about a couple ideas here if it was
computer and technology it could be like
how to build a website how to repair
computers and networks and this could
actually be like your course idea but
also you could have a video that maybe
helps you with a piece of how to build a
website and then your course explains
all the steps um how to 10x your drop
shipping business
how how to get etsy to work for your
handmade goods these are maybe niches
that would be great for creating an
online course so then what are our video
ideas you start
how
etsy works how to set up your etsy shop
and maybe your whole course is get etsy
to work for you for homemade goods arts
and crafts knitting your way to an
income right uh digital art and
photography
and and so you start maybe just teaching
about one piece of digital art or how to
create an nft or how to set up your meta
mask or your wallet writing and content
creation so secrets to publishing a book
or secrets to self-publishing a book
maybe that's your course and so what are
some pieces maybe a video is
self-publishing versus traditional
publishing these are ways that again
people can discover you on youtube
you're helping in advance
10 steps to start blogging now maybe you
just talk about
blogging trends this year and then your
course goes deep in vlogging maybe you
have a course on home exercise for
freelancers or oils and aromatherapy
children psychology for online teachers
learning investments and trading
cryptocurrency
being better with time management
and so it's a new year you start helping
people figure out you know just a couple
practical tips with time management and
then you have a whole system a whole
course to help them how to study the
bible how to be a good leader all these
different things so what is an idea and
drop it in the comments that would lead
to your online course let me know um
just one video idea that would attract
your ideal customer
that may eventually want to go deeper
with you right and be a part of your
course so the question you may have
though is okay well sean should i
actually sell on youtube though like
should i sell my course on youtube are
you saying make a youtube video and sell
my course on youtube in most cases i
would actually suggest no
maybe if your course is what you'd call
a low-cost course which is going to
probably be typically under 47 maybe
it's 27 or it's like 7 bucks it's just
something like a quick mini course but
typically
um you actually want to take the sales
conversation off of youtube it's kind of
like the idea too of like should you
sell your course on youtube and it's
also like should you
you know proposition a woman on the
first date
like probably not i mean it depends on
your culture but you know what i mean
it's like it's like maybe slow down
tiger you know it's like should you
should you just roll up like
to to to some lady you know at a
restaurant be like yo you you want to
you know get married and do the the bing
bong
that's not it's a little aggressive sir
you know uh you probably want to slow
down and so that's kind of what some
people do i think it's the mistake they
make with their online course you gotta
you gotta get to know people just add
value build relationships so how do you
do that if you're not gonna sell your
course on youtube then um where are you
ultimately gonna sell it well step two
you're going to invite viewers into a
value driven sales process to your
irresistible offer right
so what is a value-driven sales process
well
first you're creating intent-based
youtube content and you may have heard
the concept of a funnel that's kind of
what you see here so you're creating
intent-based youtube content and then
you invite people into a value-driven
sales process that could look like and
then eventually you make an offer for
your online course and hopefully that's
an irresistible offer which is a topic
for another day
so a lot of times this looks like free
premium content maybe it's like a white
paper
and that could be something maybe you do
some research some industry research
maybe you survey some people in the
industry
you consolidate case studies or
information and put it into a
downloadable pdp pdf maybe you have an
e-book that you give away from free
maybe it's uh for free maybe it's a free
checklist something that just helps
people get quick results in terms of
playing guitar in terms of health in
terms of whatever your course is about
maybe you do a challenge one of the
things that ben azadi from keto camp's
doing is he's doing a challenge
you know to help people get in shape get
some momentum and then if they love
being a part of that they could go
deeper with them maybe you do a webinar
or web class maybe an email sequence
maybe there's a five day or a seven day
or a 31 day email sequence that you set
up on an autoresponder that that adds
value and then you let people know that
you have a course you're adding value
it's a value driven sales process
people are still getting value it's not
they get value on youtube and then
you're like hey here's my course it's
they get value at every step of the way
with you you're constantly adding real
value that really helps people that
really serves people on youtube and
they're like hey if you want to go
deeper and i think the key here is free
premium content it's just another level
right
online
notice it could be an online course
maybe you give away a free online course
or what's really cool is you know with
thinkific you can
upload your course and just give away a
piece for free let people do a trial let
people just you know so it's kind of
like try before you bite you're allowed
to test drive the car right
like you're allowed to sample the
cinnabon at the mall which we don't go
to anymore in the pandemic era i don't
know about you but i would walk by with
the person with the cinnabon or the
sample at the pretzel place and i'd grab
one and then i would try to like take my
jacket off and go for a second swoop you
know what i'm saying i'll be like try to
be a different person or say um
my wife and my son would like one is
that cool can i get three and she's like
sure you may have three and then i'm
like
i just eat them all myself like
my wife's like why is there
like cinnabon
cinnamon on your lips i don't know honey
i don't know how that happened i'm
obviously kind of kidding
mini course it could be a mini course
right so maybe maybe you have something
that's more robust
uh your full academy but there's
something that's like a jump start a
couple of videos or a couple of articles
or however you want to structure it
it could be a digital download of some
kind that is
a software plug-in you know one of our
students has a course on
mpc the mixer that you make beats on and
so he has like a
a digital download of samples
sound effects and things you can use for
that
as he then gets someone's contact
information typically it's like an email
address
and what you're on youtube you're like
hey
here's free content i hope you're
enjoying this he's teaching things on
mtc do you want my sound effects pack
and my
plugins for the mpc my free pack you can
download that there's a link in the
youtube description
and then people can download that and he
has a chance to take the conversation
deeper
in a value-driven sales process and
eventually say hey would you like to
join my online course and therefore
generate sales
if you're getting value so far hit the
like button where you have step number
three and i got a couple case studies
for you um but that is here's an example
from jen devore all right so jen devore
she helps people with attraction
marketing she helps people publish their
own magazine helps kind of position
them get branded and so she's making
youtube videos here's the kind of cool
thing notice that she has 806
subscribers she hasn't been on youtube
very long like about a year and her
channel hasn't gotten huge but check it
out she's doing like 10k plus a month
maybe even more than that now
in her business how because she's
attracting the right people
you know the mistake a lot of people
make on youtube is they get too into the
numbers oh i just want to go viral like
mr beast well that's cool if your
business model is like mr beast that is
the point is going as viral as possible
but if you're in entrepreneurship or
business or you're also just looking for
a sustainable
online business based off of a thousand
true fans then really creating niche
videos that serve a specific person that
then lead
and here's how she does it here's the
intent based youtube videos that then
lead to
a
download with a 20-page magazine funnel
guide and case studies
so it's a very specific thing that she
helps people with right but she's
crushing it because her videos are
attracting the right viewers
people are learning from her
getting to know her no like and trust
and then she's like hey i got this
really valuable thing and that and
during this whole process you're
learning about her business and you go
you know what i want jen to help me make
my own magazine and really level up my
authority and my positioning see how
powerful this is and so she's inviting
people into a value-driven sales process
and there's so many different ways to
set this up we can't go into that all
here
but this is again just one example
so you still might be thinking okay but
i've tried some of these things and why
am i still not getting sales which kind
of teases up for step number three and
the reason is
is there's still probably a missing
piece or a broken piece in your business
and this
like
don't be frustrated by this i mean i
know it's frustrating
this is how every business is
like if you have posted a video and it
didn't work out for you don't call
yourself a failure everybody has posted
a bad video and probably a hundred or
hundreds in my case
right if you have created an online
course and just heard crickets and got
no sales you're not a failure you're in
the company of everyone who is
succeeding with online courses their
first version did not go good their
first try did not go great if you tried
to set up an email list and create a
lead magnet or freemium which is kind of
the beginning of your value-driven sales
process and it like and nobody wanted to
download it
don't give up the key
is small tweaks lead to giant peaks
once you build this stuff you got to go
back and just start tweaking it there
might be a broken piece or a missing
piece in your business
maybe you're making the wrong youtube
videos the cool thing is you started
making youtube videos but you gotta
tweak and level them up or change your
positioning your approach or your
methods you know maybe
the messaging and the call to action in
your videos is not working you're like
why is this video get so many views
but like no one's actually going to
the place i invited them next
well your messaging could probably be
it's probably broken or it's you got
some missing pieces right maybe your
sales process is weak or broken this is
super common it's challenging to set up
the pages that's what's cool about stuff
like thinkific because you want it to be
as easy as possible to set up like a
landing page and a place to deliver the
free thing you want to give away and
then how do you host your course and
then like how do you collect people's
payment and how do you do all these
steps well it's all there and then once
you've even set them up on a basic level
you want to go back and and do they need
to be tweaked do they need to be
improved your course positioning is
maybe weak how do you name your course
how do you make an irresistible offer
this might sound overwhelming but let's
take a deep breath i encourage you
the power of all this stuff is
to commit to essentially our third tip
which is
go back and fix
the broken pieces small tweaks lead to
giant peaks go work on one piece at a
time continuously improving the whole
process so comment below what has been
one of your aha moments from this
training so far
and let's get into oh yeah and tip
number three in just a second but i want
you to know about this
i do have a free class at
tubemasterclass.com it's on demand and
it's three surefire video ideas for
standing out in a crowded niche earning
passive income and growing from zero to
a hundred thousand subscribers quick in
this class
specifically this is going to help you
with this first step how do i make the
best intent based videos and what have
been the three most effective video
ideas that we've seen work on think
media over the last couple years again
if we're just meeting i'm your guy for
youtube right like i'll help you grow
your youtube channel get more views on
youtube um as far as you know building
out your online course we help a little
bit with that but that's our thing is
youtube you know myself and our team so
if you really want to start and grow a
youtube channel
tubemasterclass.com is the place uh to
check out this free class it's an hour
long you're gonna get a ton of value and
you're going to love it so here's step
number three
exponentially increase sales by
improving your youtube videos and your
sales process what's the missing piece
what's the broken piece
and again no like weird
i'm a failure guilt shane like
dude every business has
cracks everywhere your constant job as
an online business owner is to just
constantly be addressing
issues putting out fires fixing things
because it's just the kind of nature of
things step number one get the thing out
as soon as possible start messy
press record right get a couple videos
out my videos aren't that good yet it's
okay
get your online course good enough of
course you want to add value and be able
to be you know truly serving people but
the 1.0 version is not going to be like
the 4.0 version get your product to
market get your videos to market get
your content to market but then step
three
exponentially increase your sales by
improving your youtube videos and your
sales process
so this is carrie aguilar and he
does print on demand
so
he's really succeeded with in the past
he's on today he's done things where
he's done paid ads for people who
for niche t-shirts um if you've heard
about this industry there's different
things you could do where if you're
especially good at ads like facebook ads
and you could target somebody that like
actually lives in michigan with a
t-shirt print-on-demand that says like
michigan people are awesome and people
are like that's the perfect shirt for me
and people can you know scale different
businesses like that of course a lot of
youtube creators will create merch and
all that kind of stuff so he's become
this is just his his jam right so it's
strategy secrets and hacks to grow your
online t-shirt apparel and
print-on-demand business so really cool
channel and so he's putting out all this
valuable free content on youtube and
then
he
can send people to
uh invite people through a value driven
sales process to his different he has
multiple online courses now this is just
one of them which is uh his
i forget what it's called i just took
like a screenshot here but you can see
this is a 37 thing i think he has
academy he's got some different things
going on i think here's the key
kerry continues to tip number three his
first youtube videos weren't the best
but he just keeps making the youtube
videos a little bit better
his online course has continued to get
better
pages have continued to get better the
marketing has continued to get better
he's continue to do you can add on
multiple other ways to market as time
goes on because you're really applying
step number three your sales pages can
get better your offers can get better
and that's really the key right small
tweaks lead to giant peaks but here's
what i want you to see that's so
powerful about this number three
you want to exponentially increase
course sales
and that's going to happen not just
because you keep making new videos it's
going to happen because of something
that really only youtube offers you
and that is the power of evergreen
content because youtube is truly a
search engine and in a place that people
go to solve problems and they will watch
videos from weeks months and years ago
and let me show you how powerful this is
so kerry made this video a year ago but
using a little plug-in i can see that it
gets one vph that stands for view per
hour
okay
he made this video six months ago it
gets three v 3.3 v ph that's three views
per hour so let's do the math
that this video here on should you use
gelato print on demand
is getting 80 views a day that's 28 908
views a year
so
i think you probably are starting to see
what is the best way to market and sell
your online course this year
youtube and if you do youtube right
a video you made six months ago
is meeting people right you're adding
value you're connecting with people but
then that video is still getting 30 000
views a year and listen carrie is about
a year into his journey
so it's not too late to start youtube
larry in our community just started in
the last six months he has 53 000
subscribers people are starting today
and getting results in fact youtube is
still this is not just my opinion
data from youtube employees the
perception of some of the most
influential youtube influencers
understand that youtube is a fair
platform it is not against small
channels and it is still possible to
grow from scratch when you're making the
right videos and you understand how to
structure good content that keeps you
know
good title good thumbnail click through
rate all these different things and
that's not the point of this video
but this is why you will exponentially
grow your course sales
because
today you get everything built
1.0 version as good as possible tomorrow
you you add more videos to your library
make your sales process a little better
you sell power and you just keep
tweaking it and as you refine things in
now you've got 10 videos getting views
for you every day now you got 100 videos
getting views for every day i showed you
think media's numbers have 7 000 views
every 60 minutes it's because we saw the
power
of the matrix nobody can be told what
the matrix is you have to see it for
yourself so my question for you is are
you going to take the red pill or the
blue pill i hope you take the red pill
the youtube pill because it's time to
actually join to go into the matrix and
experience freedom for your online
course sales so listen here's how it
goes people discover you on youtube
ideal customers watch your videos 24 7
and then you invite people into your
value driven sales process and then
youtube sells your course for you when
you're not working
because once these pieces are built
right
then like carrie's video is still
getting watched from six months ago he's
hanging with his family over the
holidays but youtube is still helping
him meet people and people are going
into his value-driven sales process and
sales are happening when he's
not
working question for you is your course
already for sale let me know and how are
you marketing your course um what are
some ways you're promoting or marketing
your course what's been your experience
so far
if you find content like this valuable
hit the like button and actually i want
to invite you
check out tubemasterclass.com because if
your next
question is like okay well teach me more
about youtube i want to learn more about
youtube then you're absolutely going to
love this class it's free of course at
the end of it i'll let you know about
our main online course which is all
about youtube like if you want to master
youtube get results on youtube scale
youtube i think it's one of the smartest
things to do because one of the cool
things that we didn't get to touch on
is a lot of course creators are
dependent just on their online course
sales
at think media between personal and
investment streams and business streams
of income we have 21 different streams
of income that's a little much if you're
just starting but that's the power and
scalability of youtube ad revenue and
affiliate marketing and brand deals and
sponsorships that can all come as a
result of you also taking action on
youtube and so again if you want to go a
little bit deeper check that out in the
uh the link in the description down
below and i think you will absolutely
love that i also really appreciate you
and here's a big challenge though that
it will actually help you right now
how do you name your course how do you
actually name your course position your
course and come up with the name because
that could be one of the main reasons
the huge mistake people make is they
position their content their course
their book wrong
and i learned something from my friend
rory vaden we have a video here on think
media click or tap the screen to watch
it it's on five title tips this is one
of the most probably the most
life-changing videos interviews i've
been a part of this year so click or tap
the screen to watch that and i can't
wait to see you in a future episode of
coffee with kennel